gonna make everyone even more depressed
let's do it hell yes let's do it please
do let's go so uh the thing that really
upsets me is the virtual certainty that
nothing will happen as a consequence of
this and let me give you an example when
this happened we all remember that Brett
Kavanaugh hearings and the what are you
where do you think of Christine blasey
Ford Julie swetnik was an example where
it absolutely you know she's saying that
Kavanaugh was at these parties where
there was trains run on her it's like
why are you going back to these parties
Michael avenatti was her lawyer people
were tripping over themselves to put her
on TV it turned out her story made no
sense it didn't add up she never met
Kavanaugh so and so forth
um Chuck Grassley Charles Grassley was
just re-elected who was I think head of
the Judiciary Committee ranking hardcore
Republican he put out press release Earl
this year how he wrote a letter to both
the Department of Justice and the FBI
asking for follow-up but someone who
lied to you know affect a free Court
nomination and they didn't bother reply
neither bothered replying to him